et pour parler de la réforme des
retraites dans un contexte politique
mouvant michel fize sociologue est avec
nous sur ce plateau michel fize bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
on l'a vu aujourd'hui du monde dans les
rues c'est plutôt selon vous un acte
symbolique ou encore un réel espoir d'un
retrait de la réforme des retraites
je crois qu'on peut encore parler de
détermination parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'à chaque niveau de discussion ça se
termine par un blocage sept et les cas
avec la commission spéciale qui n'a pu
exhiber et examiné qu'une partie qu'une
partie des amendements donc aujourd'hui
avec le projet de loi mise en lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
je pense que ça renforce au contraire la
détermination parce que les moyens de
contrecarrer ce projet sont quand même
très très limité dans cette démocratie
une détermination néanmoins entachée par
des feuilles de paye parfois à 0 pour
certains qui se sont beaucoup mobilisées
lé indiqué avait d'ailleurs appelé à une
journée morte dans les transports on le
constate les transports fonctionnent
plutôt bien aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya un essoufflement
justement non mais enfin on peut quand
même regretter que pour un système qui
devait être est plus simple et plus
juste
il apparaît terriblement complexe est
particulièrement injuste puisque encore
une fois je crois que l'exécutif a
confondu l'universalisme et
l'égalitarisme oubliant d'ailleurs le
sens des mots moi je suis quand même
toujours surpris de constater qu'on
oublie le sens véritable démo qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un régime universel un
régime universel selon le dictionnaire
c'est un régime qui s'applique à tout le
monde donc c'est un régime commun quand
on sait que ce système a été présenté
pour faire disparaître les régimes
sociaux
il est évident dans la pensée de
l'exécutif il y avait vraiment la
volonté qu'il y ait un régime unique
voilà le même régime pour tout le monde
bon encore une fois je pense qu'un
régime de retraite
doit s'appuyer au contraire sur l'équité
et l'équité ben passe par la prise en
compte des différences art on voit bien
que toutes les catégories sociales sont
maltraités par par ce nouveau système
depuis le cheminot qui perdent leur
régime le régime spécial bond en passant
par les policiers les les avocats donc
je crois que ce serait ce régime qui
nous est présentée nourrit beaucoup
d'inquiétude
bon sans compter encore une fois toutes
les approximations les incertitudes qui
subsistent bon notamment la beaucoup
parlé de la valeur du point
donc maintenant c'est plus du tout sur
quoi va être calculée ce point est
justement fin janvier c'est la porte
parole du gouvernement qui disait en
fait que le rejet de cette réforme des
retraites était lié davantage à un
manque de compréhension de la part des
français c'est le cas non alors ça c'est
l'argument classique quand on ne
parvient pas à se faire entendre on
dégaine l'idée que c'est parce qu'on
s'est mal expliqué que les français ont
mal compris
non je crois que les français ont très
bien compris et ils sont inquiets sur un
niveau de pension parce que finalement
bon chacun a conscience que le niveau
actuel n'est pas n'est pas garanti
malgré les pare feux qui s'appelle
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
enseignants par exemple les garanties
accordées aux aux avocats qu'ils ne
perdront pas leur cagnotte
voilà mais tout ça est évidemment
lourdes d'orage la bataille va jouer
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle désormais
c'est fini la rue pour vous ce je ne
pense pas parce qu'il ya une douille à
un double combat il ya le combat au
parlement
bon qui risque quand même d'être perdu
d'abord parce qu'il ya des dates qui
sont déjà posés 1 le 4 mars vote de du
du projet avec d'ailleurs toutes les
menaces qui peuvent peser puisque je
rappelle que l'exécutif à deux armes le
vote bloqué d'une part qui permet de ne
retenir que les amendements qui lui
conviennent et puis le fameux article 49
3 qui n'est pas à mon sens complètement
écartée
justement il ya effectivement cette
rumeur qui dit qu emmanuel macron
n'exclurait pas ce 49 3
c'est quoi ce serait l'occasion de
passer à autre chose dans la douleur
certes ou alors au contraire ça pourrait
davantage attisé la colère se retrouva
sa satire est peut-être la colère déjà
au sein même de l'exécutif parce qu'il
semble que le premier ministre n'est pas
du tout favorable et une partie de la
majorité parlementaire
aussi n'est pas favorable à recourir 7,7
cet outil voilà qui est un outil quand
même particulièrement peu démocratique
savez moi je pense que si ce qui se joue
dans cette affaire de retraite
c'est la question qui avait évoqué un
ancien président de la république quand
il appelait un statut de l'opposition
voilà bon on fustige beaucoup le recours
aux amendements mais qu'elle est quel
autre outil à l'opposition actuellement
la motion de censure ne peut pas passer
faute d'avoir un nombre suffisants pour
la faire adopter donc il reste que
l'amendement
je pense pas qu'on puisse parler de
d'obstruction c'est pas de l'obstruction
c'est l'utilisation des moyens des
petits moyens qui restent à disposition
de l'opposition
donc moi je pense qu'on devrait aussi
réfléchir à a inventé un système qui
reconnaissent des droits à l'opposition
ce qui veut dire encore une fois sortir
de la toute-puissance présidentielle qui
caractérise ce régime mais j'aurais pu
dire la même chose du temps de monsieur
hollande ou de monsieur sarkozy c'est
quand même la vème république qui est en
question aujourd'hui
alors justement il y avait 140
personnalités qui ont appelé un
référendum sur cette question des
retraites c'était le 10 février dernier
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
serait audible aujourd'hui dans le
contexte selon vous ce serait
probablement une décision qui aurait
l'avantagé de la clarté à condition que
la question posée soit bien formulée et
ne prêtent pas ne prête pas ambiguïté
et puis ça correspondrait à une
définition de la démocratie
au terme de laquelle est bien le pouvoir
souverain revient revient au peuple
c'est lui qui tranche en dernier
dernière analyse
voilà mais si chaque partie est d'accord
pour accepter le verdict évidemment du
référendum bas je pense qu'on sortirait
de cette crise
alors une réforme des retraites
également marqué ces dernières heures
par le changement un changement de
ministres celui d'agnès busin par
olivier ferrand au ministère de la santé
beaucoup s'interrogent sur ce changement
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
stratégie justement en plein débat de la
réforme des retraites alors d'abord bon
il apparaît je pense clair que c'est un
changement qui a été imposée à la
ministre quand on voit la réaction avec
la passation de pouvoir tout à l'heure
on ne peut pas en douter un seul instant
bon peut-être que dans l'est dans
l'esprit du président madame d'uzein
présente les les qualités un certain
nombre d'atouts pour venir s'installer
dans cette espèce de combat pour la
mairie de paris
voilà mais je pense qu'encore une fois
en marche par de très très loin et je
doute quand même que madame busin puisse
rattraper les deux candidates en tête
madame hidalgo et madame dati
merci beaucoup michel fize d'avoir
partagé votre analyse sur notre plateau
je rappelle que cette sociologue et
auteur notamment d'une insurrection
populaire au destin encore incertain aux
éditions amazon